oh take a look at the overall numbers
for mike
overall 2-8 5-17 doesn't look that great
but as m was talking about you look at
his last three starts it's gotten much
better
he's had a 192 opponent's average in his
last three starts it'll be another good
crowd here this afternoon better than 29
000 at globe life field last night
there's a one-two and there's a fastball
hit weekly to third brock holt comes
over
throws the first and makes a very nice
play to kick things off here this
afternoon one retired for mike fulton
it's always a mystery it seems
part of the
mystique i guess with faulty is what's
the hairstyle going to be and the hair
down this afternoon
elvis does not yes he did offer at that
breaking ball and he is down on strikes
faulty was the pitcher on
the fourth of july in seattle suffered
the 4-1 loss he gave up four runs in
seven innings and here a fastball swing
and a miss
and olson is out on strikes as fulton
evac retires the side in order to begin
our game today and james caprilian on
the mount for the athletics his 11th
start thinking back to his first major
league start against the boston red sox
how well he dived in and how well he's
done for the athletics with a 284 earned
run average and his third against texas
is four in three with a 284 era he's
allowed just 41 hits in 57 innings
holt hits a high pop up
down the third base line chapman back
there and chapman reaches up and makes a
nice running catch here's it alice
garcia he had the game-winning hit
yesterday well garcia hits a high fly
ball to right field and this one
is gone adoles garcia on the first pitch
that he sees from james cabrillo
it's his 22nd home run
of the season and picks up his 62nd rbi
rangers lead at one nothing with joey
gala now stepping in and he swings and
hits a high fly ball to deep right field
and that is gone
[Applause]
and joey gallo both rangers all-stars
getting it done in a big way here in the
first inning
that one grounded
to the backhand by elvis sanders he gets
up
and throws out jonah high
elvis anders
tough play
knocked it down then had to find it and
make a good throw and he did to get
jonah high here's murphy
murphy with a shot to left field and
that baby's gone
second deck
i think you said it as last night it
seems like every time murph goes to the
plate he's angry
and
he might be real angry because he was
behind the plate when those two home
runs were hit
this was a no doubter brown a
left-handed batter hitting 183 but with
nine home runs and 27 runs batted in
brown smokes one right center that's
deep and that baby's gone i thought home
run derby is monday night in colorado
wow
so murphy and brown go back to back home
run number 10 for seth brown
in here to left field
going back is bolt bolt at the wall and
he's got just enough room to make the
catch
seems like for some reason to me we've
talked about this in the past
he can't get away with any mistakes it
just seems like mistakes get capitalized
on you see pitchers get away with
mistakes all the time there's a good
looking slide around the corner paul
strike three and loriano is down
for the second out here in the third 3-2
swing and a miss fastball gets him so
caprilian has two strikeouts both coming
against nate lowe
the
that one's fouled off of chapman in the
box and he immediately drops to his
knees
he's on all fours
and he fights off the discomfort
slowly tries to get to his feet
is still down that is hard off the field
matt chapman's not the kind to stay down
oh boy that got him good
and chapman can hold up he is down on
strikes and so mike fulton evidence with
a strikeout here
in the fourth inning retiring matt
chapman and here's jed lowry infielders
on the right side against larry here's
the 2-1
deep to right field dahl is back at the
wall and it is gone so jed lowry a high
towering drive
reaches the seats to give the a's a
three to two lead
line toward the gap and it's over the
head of martin bangs off the wall
and seth brown has got himself a
lead-off double
ranger pitchers have been using that
two-seam fastball a little bit more we
talked about jordan lyles yesterday and
now mike fulton and there's another
fastball two-seam fastball that is
turned on and hit foul and what a play
by a random royals fan apparently
that one-handed that was it to the right
guy if you want to see a catch by a fan
see the shaking head there mike falton
evans he's trying to get that slider
away the breaking ball might have been
the curball at 79.
but after the fastball in he's trying to
now work gloriano away
and there's a breaking ball on the
outside corner loriano pops it straight
away to center field adolesce garcia is
there the inning is over nice job by
mike boltonevich to pitch around a
leadoff double it is still three to
he's grounded two he's got it flips to
chapman chapman on the first double play
three five three double play
nicely done by the athletics to end
the bottom of the fifth
and two one is a ground ball hit to the
left side isaiah kind of flip it over to
second for one in the first double play
six four three
for the rangers and a big double play
here in the a thing a nice job by taylor
hearn to induce that ground ball so
jonah heim will step in against jake
steepman and for the first time
in this game will get an opportunity
to bat right-handed
and here is that one-two pitch and a
fastball hit to the right side that's
going to be a base hit right around
third he's gonna come home he will score
and the rangers have tied this game up
three to three jonah heim with the
opposite field base hit
joey gallow goes first to third
and the rangers in business here in the
bottom of the eight here's the pitch
through the ground ball left side connor
fell off a backhanded snag but he has no
play
as he got to his feet he slipped just
enough to prevent him from even issuing
a throw to first
i don't know that he gets lorianno even
if he gets up cleanly
and it's an infield rbi single for ramon
loriano and the aides take a 4-3 lead
here in the top of the
they don't want anything to get over
their head joey gallo can run anything
that gets past an outfielder this game
could be over and so they are playing a
little bit deeper to try to prevent that
here's the 3-0 and heim swings and hits
a hard shot to the right side off the
glove of wilson he flips to andrews
and joey gallo is ruled out i don't know
if that is going to hold we'll see if
the rangers want to take a look at it
but more importantly eli white scores
and this game is tied and
joe west says he's safe how about it
so it'll be a fielder's choice but more
importantly first and second
with one out here's the bonus
hits it hard
out at second and that's a double play
so we roll on from arlington
pitch here it is
it's grounded into right field of base
hit
here comes alva andrus eli white's throw
is late it's an rbi single for jed lowry
and the a's recapture the lead it's 5-4
matt olson able to go to third that's
huge
to the backstop and trying to scores
olson and he will score
and on a spencer patton wild pitch the
a's get an insurance run here and now
lead six to four and that brings up
steven piscotti biscotti who reached on
a nick solanke error his only at-bat in
the 10th inning
and that one is it deep to left field
martin back and that baby's gone
oh what a great sound off the bat of
stephen biscotti he knew it for samer
right down the middle at that point
steven said got it
[Applause]
he lines one into the glove of chapman
and that's the ball game so these even
up the
series they had a game of peace they'll
try to win it tomorrow